is Mother Nature's gonna turn up the
flame and the wind machine today two
guys so we're gonna have to deal with
more than just one thing to concentrate
on let's look outside beautiful shot of
the leftover moon hanging over the
spring mountains right now that is
gorgeous
temperatures a mix of mostly 80s some
upper 70s and we're looking at Wow a hot
week a slight dip in temps but we've got
to deal with dry gusty winds today red
flag warnings and wind advisory for the
lake the weekend is going to bring a lot
of heat our hottest of the year so far
at 110 plus so 105 close to normal not
terrible but boy once we get to the end
of the week that's when we're going to
feel the burn breezy winds through
Thursday windy today tomorrow breezy
Thursday and hot downright hot Nate for
Saturday Sunday Monday
I don't care nobody can argue with me
but that's not hot people argue about
whether they enjoy that and they still
boggles my mind sherry that some folks
love the one teens and they can have
them you can